MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Die Tornadojagd beginnt im
amerikanischen Bundesstaat Texas.
Im Mai geht hier nämlich
die Tornado-Saison los.
Dominic
reist mit seinen Freund Sascha.
Die beiden Stormchaser lernten sich
vor elf Jahren in der Schweiz kennen.
Die Aufgaben sind klar verteilt:
Sascha sitzt am Steuer und Dominic
sucht am Laptop nach Sturmzellen.
Ich betreibe Stormchasing
wegen der Faszination vor der Natur.
Es ist einfach toll zu sehen,
was das Wetter alles machen kann.
Die Gewalt und Kraft der Natur spürt
man hier in den Staaten extrem gut.
Mir gibt es Kraft und Energie
für den Alltag.
Wenn man hier so ein Erfolgserlebnis
hat - das nimmt man mit.
An den drei Wochen,
die ich hier in den Staaten bin,
werde ich fast ein ganzes Jahr lang
zehren.
Es ist, wie wenn jemand Schlümpfe
sammelt oder so etwas.
Ich sammle einfach
quasi meine Tornados.
Über ein Jahr lang haben
die beiden die Reise vorbereitet -
jetzt müssen sie nur noch zur rich-
tigen Zeit am richtigen Ort sein.
* Perlende Klänge *
Botswana, im Süden
des afrikanischen Kontinents.
Hier lebt der Schweizer
Christian Gross.
Er hat vor sechs Jahren
die Okavango Air Rescue gegründet.
Eine Rettungsflugwacht
ähnlich der Schweizer Rega.
Wir haben einen Flug
von Gaborone nach Durban.
Jetzt fliegen wir
von Maun nach Gaborone.
Dort nehmen wir den Patienten auf.
In ca. 10 Min. sind wir in der Luft.
Christian ist Unternehmer,
die Einsätze fliegt sein Team.
Meistens mit dabei
ist auch Misha Kruck:
Sie ist Notfallärztin
und Christians Lebenspartnerin.
Mit dieser PC-12 aus der Schweiz
hebt sie fast täglich ab,
um Leben zu retten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik,
Motorengeräusche *
Heute haben wir ein acht Tage altes
Neugeborenes,
das eine sog. Transposition
der grossen Gefässe hat.
D.h. die Anschlüsse vom Herzen
zur Lunge und zum Körper
sind nicht
in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Und dadurch bekommt das Kind
nicht genug Sauerstoff
in sein System.
Wenn man das nicht
operativ reparieren wird,
wird das Kind in den nächsten Tagen
sterben.
Die Herausforderung beim Flug ist,
dass diese Verbindung vom Herzen
nicht durch zu viel Sauerstoffgabe
geschlossen wird.
Dann wären wir
in grossen Schwierigkeiten.
Der Flug kann von absolut easy
bis zu hoch kompliziert enden.
Wir hoffen natürlich,
dass es absolut easy ist.
Wir geben unser Bestes,
dass es so sein wird.
Die Basis der Okavango Air Rescue
liegt im Städtchen Maun,
mitten im Okavango Delta.
Die Gegend ist bekannt
für ihre vielen wilden Tiere
und beliebt bei Touristen.
Von hier aus fliegt das Team
von Misha und Christian
seine Einsätze in das unwegsame
Gebiet des Okovango-Flusses.
Für den Weltenbummler Christian
ist Botswana ein Zuhause geworden.
Mit knapp 20
wanderte ich aus der Schweiz aus.
Ich lebte mein ganzes Leben
im Ausland.
Heute in Botswana.
Die Okawango Air Rescue
gibt es seit sechs Jahren.
In den ersten zwei Jahren
waren die Leute etwas misstrauisch,
ob wir das erste Jahr
überleben würden.
Aber wir sind jedes Jahr
stetig gewachsen.
Wir haben rund 30 Angestellte.
Momentan vier Ärzte
und vier Piloten.
Und Krankenschwestern, Paramedics,
Notfallsanitäter.
Somit wurde das keine Halbpensio-
nierung, sondern ein Vollzeitjob.
Und das ist gross.
Mittlerweile landen Misha
und ihre Crew in Gaborone.
Hier wartet
ein vier Monate alter Patient
auf den lebenswichtigen Flug
ins Spital nach Durban.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Wie ist sein Name?
- Kensington.
Willkommen in unserem kleinen
Flugzeug, Kensington.
Hast du gehört,
du bekommst ein Privatflugzeug.
Lass uns kurz Hallo sagen.
Das ist Kensington.
Und Kensington fliegt nach Durban
für eine grosse Operation.
Und jetzt bringen wir ihn
in unser kleines Bett
und machen es ihm dort schön bequem.
Thank you.
* Sie spricht leise mit ihm. *
Okay, it's going to be right.
Just for a second, ja, ja, I know.
Misha und ich
trafen uns in der Luft.
Vor elf Jahren ging ich auf
die Jagd, aber nur für zwei Tage.
Dann wollte ich noch nach Spanien,
um meine Mutter zu besuchen.
Wir sassen im Flugzeug und
hatten schon 6 Std. Verspätung.
Die Atmosphäre im Flugzeug
war sehr angespannt.
Das war eine kleine Gruppe,
sechs Leute, auch Christian.
Und die Dame, die auf der anderen
Seite sass, war Misha.
Sie arbeitete ja in den Bergen.
Und als ich ganz verspätet, mit
meiner Jagdkluft ins Flugzeug kam,
meinte sie: "Der Mann aus den Ber-
gen fliegt wohl zum ersten Mal."
Die Stewardess fragte ihn dann,
ob er etwas trinken wollte,
ob alles in Ordnung sei.
Er hat kein Wort verstanden
und ich dachte mir:
"Jesses, das ist auch so ein
Sozialfall, dem muss ich helfen."
"Der hört nicht mal gut."
So kamen wir ins Gespräch.
Wir fanden uns offensichtlich
sympathisch.
Und ... Ja, the rest is history.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Zurück in die Schweiz,
nach Amriswil im Kanton Thurgau.
Auf diesen Tag hat Jonas Langenegger
sehnsüchtig gewartet.
Heute kann er zum ersten Mal seinen
neuen Segelkunstflieger ausprobieren.
Aber zuerst muss er
fertig zusammengebaut werden.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Also, ich schaue noch kurz,
was wichtig ist.
Ich habe eine Liste gemacht,
da staunst du, oder?
Er hat einen eigenen Flieger
und nimmt das ernst.
Der Flieger ist halt noch neu.
Ich will ihm sowieso Sorge tragen -
aber jetzt ist es schon anders.
Ja, damit ich sicher nicht schon
bei der Montage einen Fehler mache -
es wäre schade, wenn ich
nachher nicht fliegen könnte.
Es geht fast einfacher zum Tragen.
Okay, drehen.
Gut schauen.
Du kannst ihn anheben,
dann tragen wir ihn beide zusammen.
Irgendwie ist etwas nicht ganz ...
Kannst du noch einmal
ein wenig hoch?
Ah, ja, logisch. Sorry.
Hier muss man
durch drei Dinge durch.
Ich glaube, das ist drin.
Es ist ungewohnt,
weil es ein polnischer Flieger ist,
da ist alles ein wenig anders.
Später versuchen wir mal,
zu fliegen.
Das Wichtigste ist,
sich an den Flieger zu gewöhnen.
2018 wurde Jonas
Weltmeister im Segelkunstflug,
und zwar in der Kategorie Advanced.
Jochen Reuter ist sein Trainer.
Beim Aussenrollenkreis
ist der Anfang wichtig.
Du hebst ihn leicht aus, das kannst
du am Anfang bewusst machen.
Wie mit der 21.
Jetzt schiebt der so hin, du kippst
das Seitenruder nach oben.
So hast du die Nase oben -
jetzt geht es automatisch.
Jetzt stösst du einfach durch, zack.
Du hast die ersten 45.
- Genau.
Du drehst weiter,
das Seitenruder in Kurvenrichtung.
das Seitenruder immer noch oben.
Es ist oben, wenn du weiterdrehst.
- Genau, ja.
So und jetzt: genau so, zack.
Die Koordination ist ganz anders
als beim normalen Fliegen.
Die Eindrücke, die Beschleunigung,
die Geschwindigkeit, der Horizont.
Man hängt in den Gurten,
der Flieger schiebt.
Das ist so anders
als das normale Fliegen,
man muss das lange und ausführlich
üben.
Jetzt muss ich noch dehnen.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Ja, ich bin gleich bereit.
(Funk) Wie schnell möchtest du
geschleppt werden?
Ach so, wie schnell. 130 wäre gut.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Als Fluglehrer ist man sich gewohnt,
seine Kenntnisse weiterzugeben.
Es macht Freude, wenn das so junge
Leute sind, die es umsetzen.
Und es z.T. genau so machen, wie
man es gerne selbst gemacht hätte.
* Treibende Klänge *
Bei solchen Figuren
wirken enorme Kräfte von 7G.
Jonas wird mit dem Siebenfachen
seines Gewichts
in den Sitz gedrückt.
Jede Bewegung
wird vom Trainer genau beobachtet.
Dieser spricht das Feedback
auf ein Diktiergerät.
Auf die Drehgeschwindigkeit achten.
Die erste war ca. 25°.
Und der Rest auf 80°.
Er ist auf jeden Fall
ein ausgesprochenes Talent.
Das verführt ihn manchmal dazu,
zu glauben, alles gehe von selbst.
Das tut es nicht.
Aber das gehört auch zur Entwicklung
eines Sportlers dazu.
Dieses Programm will Jonas
an den Schweizermeisterschaften
in drei Monaten
vor einer Punkte-Jury fliegen.
Für den ersten Flug
war das nicht schlecht.
Es waren die typischen Probleme,
die immer auftreten.
Das ist eine Frage der Zeit,
bis es gut klappt.
Es macht Spass -
aber es gibt noch einiges zu lernen.
Die erste Figur
gelang mir erstaunlich gut.
Aber das war wohl
eher Anfängerglück.
Aber die ersten Rollenkreise waren
noch nicht so, wie sie sein sollten.
Der 25-Jährige
ist ein Ausnahmetalent.
Er will sein Können in diesem Jahr
in der höchsten Segelflugkategorie
beweisen - der Unlimited-Klasse.
Die bekannten Figuren waren gut, die
unbekannten müssen wir noch üben.
Das war zu erwarten.
Und den Stil - von Anfang an
exakter und akzentuierter.
Ja.
- Gut.
Im Prinzip das Gleiche noch einmal.
- Ja, ich glaube auch.
Mein Ziel ist, an den Schweizermeis-
terschaften aufs Podest zu fliegen.
Es gibt natürlich auch einen Druck,
weil ich in der Kategorie Advanced
die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen habe.
Jetzt will ich auch in der Kategorie
Unlimited ganz vorne dabei sein.
Doch dort ist die Luft dünn, nur
die Besten treten gegeneinander an.
Bald wird sich zeigen,
ob Jonas mit ihnen mithalten kann.
Ein paar Tausend Kilometer
weiter westlich.
Die Schweizer Sturmjäger
Dominic und Sascha
sind auf dem Weg nach Nebraska,
ins Tornadogebiet.
In der Nähe von El Reno
legen sie einen Zwischenstopp
bei einer Gedenkstätte ein.
Hier sind drei Stormchaser
auf ihrer Jagd nach den
Riesenstürmen ums Leben gekommen.
2015 gab es diese Tafel noch nicht.
Das ist schön gemacht.
Sie waren zu dritt unterwegs,
es war am 31. Mai 2013.
Es gab bei El Rino
einen alles zerstörenden Tornado.
Bei El Rino
gab es einen grossen Tornado.
Und rundherum
wirbelten kleinere Tornados.
Und sie wurden von einem kleineren
getroffen.
Tim Samares war noch im Auto,
dieses wurde angehoben
es wurde weit weg gewindet.
Paul und Carl
wurden aus dem Auto hinausgezogen.
Sie waren mit dem Sicherheitsgurt
angeschnallt -
aber es entstand so eine Kraft, dass
sie aus dem Auto gezogen wurden.
Das sind die Gegenstände,
die man im Auto gefunden hat,
oder irgendwo verteilt waren.
Sicherheit geht vor.
Ich bin Vater von zwei Kindern.
Ich will noch erleben,
wie sie erwachsen werden.
Das ist wichtig.
Angezogen
von der Magie der Naturgewalt,
fasziniert von der möglichen Gefahr,
steuern Dominic und Sascha
auf die Gewitterzelle zu,
aus der ein Tornado werden soll.
* Spannungsvolle Musik *
Ich schaue
die aktuelle Modellprognose an.
Die zeigt an,
wo mögliche Superzellen sind.
D.h.: Wie sieht es in der Höhe aus,
welche Winde gibt es?
Wie ist die Windschärung? Also
einerseits die Drehung der Winde,
es können auch stärkere Winde sein,
hier gibt es Orkanstärke.
Wenn es eine Superzelle hat,
begünstigt das einen Tornado.
Ein Tornado entsteht eigentlich nur
aus einer Superzelle.
Wir müssen uns sowieso verschieben.
Wir müssen ca. 4 Std.
Richtung Westen.
Morgen werden wir also
nochmals 8-12 Std. fahren -
je nachdem, wohin wir wollen.
Die Prognose, die er jetzt
anschaut, für Freitagabend, zeigt,
wo wirklich die ganz starken Gewit-
ter sind, die uns interessieren.
Und das ist ...
... auch eine Kunst,
er muss das genau sehen,
sonst sind wir plötzlich mittendrin,
was etwas tödlich sein kann.
Das versuchen wir also zu vermeiden.
(Lachend) Etwas tödlich ...
Auch in Andwil in St. Gallen
lebt ein Mann,
der sich mit Leib und Seele
dem Element Luft verschrieben hat.
In seiner Werkstatt bereitet sich
Ballonpilot Stefan Zeberli
auf eine abenteuerliche Reise vor.
Ja, jetzt ist es perfekt.
Aber etwas höher.
Mit seinem Co-Piloten Urs
will Stefan in Argentinien
auf 7'000 m ü. M. aufsteigen
und mit dem Ballon
über die Anden fahren.
Als Profi-Ballonfahrer unternimmt
Stefan rund 200 Fahrten pro Jahr.
Aber keine ist vergleichbar mit dem,
was er in Argentinien vorhat.
Wir bereiten den Korb
für Argentinien vor.
Er kommt auf eine Palette, geht dann
mit der Spedition nach Spanien,
dann mit dem Schiff
nach Argentinien.
Damit wir dort einen
funktionierenden Ballon haben,
checken wir jetzt alles: den Bren-
ner, die Sauerstoffeinrichtung ...
Damit wir nicht dort etwas merken,
was man hier hätte vermeiden können.
Bei Fahrten in solche Gebirge,
wo wir sehr hoch steigen,
nehmen wir Sauerstoff mit.
Danke.
Die Höhe macht auch müde. Das darf
man auch nicht ausser Acht lassen.
Man muss vor einer solchen Ballon-
fahrt also auch körperlich fit sein.
Wie im Spital.
Wie viele Stunden hält eine Flasche?
Nehmen wir nur eine mit?
Wir schicken zwei Zweiliter-
flaschen. Das ist eine mit 3,5 l.
Nur die besten Piloten der Welt
trauen sich eine solche Fahrt zu.
Die Bedingungen sind extrem.
Auf 4'000 m sind es 80 km/h,
auf 5'000 m 120 km/h.
Dort brauchen wir den Wind, oder?
Genau, das brauchen wir
bei der langen Fahrt über Chile.
Eine Herausforderung
ist schon einmal die neue Umgebung.
Das Wetter -
niemand ist wirklich vertraut damit.
Und man kann keine eigenen,
lokalen Erfahrungswerte einbringen.
Das ist eine Grundschwierigkeit, die
man in einem fremden Land halt hat.
Hello.
- Hello, Joseph.
Die Fahrt über die Anden
wird von einem Profi organisiert.
Joseph hat 50 Ballonfahrer
aus der ganzen Welt dazu eingeladen.
Stefan gehört zu den
erfahrensten Piloten der Gruppe
und hilft darum
bei den Vorbereitungen.
Ich glaube,
das ist die komplizierteste Reise,
die ich je organisiert habe.
Die Winde sind sehr stark.
Und die einzige Chance,
die wir haben,
ist während diesen
kurzen Zeitfenstern.
Also, lasst uns hoffen. Wir brauchen
schon ein bisschen Glück.
Nebst all den üblichen Heraus-
forderungen wartet dieses Mal
ein ganz besonderes Naturspektakel
auf die Ballonfahrer:
eine totale Sonnenfinsternis
im Westen Argentiniens.
Wir müssen zur richtigen Zeit
am vordefinierten Ort sein.
Zur richtigen Zeit
auf der richtigen Höhe.
Also: Die Sonnenbrille
nicht vergessen.
Das ist für mich ballonfahrerisch
gesehen schon das Highlight.
Ich stelle mir das natürlich
auch extrem spannend vor.
Diese kurzen Minuten mitzuerleben,
in denen tagsüber auf einem schmalen
Streifen totale Dunkelheit herrscht.
Ist gut?
Um diese totale Sonnenfinsternis
aus dem Ballon mitzuerleben,
braucht Stefan
beste Wetterverhältnisse,
einwandfreies Material
und ein bisschen Glück.
Sein Ballon macht sich
schon ein paar Wochen vor ihm
auf die lange Reise
nach Argentinien.
Wir befinden uns in Osttimor.
Der kleine Inselstaat
liegt in Südostasien
und gehört
zu den ärmsten Ländern der Welt.
Let's pray. We thank you
for giving us opportunities.
Blessing us, each and every day.
Heiliger Vater, ich danke dir für
die Menschen, die uns unterstützen.
Ich möchte auch dankbar sein
für unser Team hier.
Beschütze die Frauen und Männer,
die heute eingeliefert wurden,
und gib den Ärzten die Weisheit,
um sie richtig zu behandeln,
damit sie schnell gesund werden.
Morgengebet auf dem Flughafen
der Mission Aviation Fellowship,
kurz MAF.
Das christliche Flugunternehmen
hilft Menschen in Not -
mit Hilfsflügen
und mit dem Beistand von ganz oben.
Die Vision ist, dass wir Leute,
die abgelegen leben, unterstützen
und ihnen helfen.
Und dies mit der Liebe, die wir
zu Gott haben und Gott uns gibt.
Daniel Moser arbeitet seit
vier Jahren als Pilot für die MAF.
Heute muss er sich um Probleme
auf einer Landepiste kümmern.
Der heutige Plan ist,
dass wir nach Lospalos fliegen,
ein kleiner Ort ganz im Osten
der Insel, 45 Min. von hier.
Wir müssen
mit einem Bauarbeiter schauen,
ob sie die Löcher im Runway
flicken können.
Für die Sicherheit ist es extrem
wichtig, ein Fluglandefeld zu haben,
auf dem wir landen können,
ohne einzusinken.
In Lospalos
ist das gerade nicht der Fall.
Bei starkem Regenfall
wird der Boden, rund 150 m, weich.
Dann können wir dort nicht
aufsetzen, wir würden einsinken.
Daniel
hat eigentlich Schreiner gelernt.
Danach ging er
als Fallschirmaufklärer
mit der Swisscoy der Schweizer Armee
in den Kosovo.
Clear Prop. Prop ist clear.
* Ratternde Motorengeräusche *
It is Monday morning.
Nach seiner Zeit im Kosovo
heuerte Daniel bei der
Mission Aviation Fellowship an.
Die christliche Organisation
ist in 26 Ländern im Einsatz.
Dank ihr konnte sich Daniel
hier in Osttimor
zum Missionspiloten
ausbilden lassen.
Der Glaube an die christliche Lehre
treibt Daniel an, Gutes zu tun.
Letztendlich hat jeder Mensch
gewisse Fähigkeiten und Stärken.
Ich bin in einem Elternhaus
aufgewachsen, in dem ich viel bekam.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass der
christliche Glaube den Ursprung hat,
dass wir anderen helfen -
in welcher Form auch immer.
Für mich ist das eine Art,
wie ich diesen Leuten helfen kann,
in der Zeit, in der ich hier bin -
in der Schweiz sieht es anders aus.
Für mich ist momentan dieser Glaube,
den ich habe,
der christliche Glaube,
ist die treibende Kraft dahinter,
die mich hierhin gebracht hat.
* Emotionale Klänge *
Osttimor ist ein kleiner Inselstaat
zwischen Indonesien und Australien.
Die Halbinsel hat 1 Mio. Einwohner,
aber nur jeder zweite
hat Zugang zu sauberem Trinkwasser.
Ein Drittel der Bevölkerung
ist arbeitslos.
Um Hilfseinsätze fliegen zu können,
müssen die wichtigsten Landebahnen
in einem guten Zustand sein.
Diese Piste ist nach starken
Regenfällen voller Schlaglöcher.
Da haben wir
ein ca. 40 cm tiefes Loch.
Das würde nichts Gutes bedeuten,
wenn wir hinein kämen.
Dieses Stück hier muss aufgefüllt
und ausnivelliert werden.
Und v.a. dieser Mittelteil ―
der muss wieder schön gerade sein.
Wie viel kostet das -
und wie viel das da drüben?
Aber bevor Daniel
dieses Problem lösen kann,
muss er sich
um etwas Dringenderes kümmern:
Ganz in der Nähe hat eine Frau
einen Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Okay and we can take
one patient with us.
Okay, great. Yes.
Vielleicht ist es Fügung,
dass der Schweizer zur richtigen
Zeit am richtigen Ort ist:
Der Krankenwagen
bringt die Patientin
innert Minuten zum Flugzeug.
Sie muss schnellstmöglich
ins Krankenhaus.
Was hat die Patientin
für ein Problem?- Herzinfarkt.
Daniels Transportflüge
können in Osttimor Leben retten.
Viele Gebiete auf der Insel sind
mit dem Auto nur schwer erreichbar,
und eine Fahrt ins nächste
Krankenhaus würde Stunden dauern.
Daniel und sein Team fliegen
v.a. kranke ältere Personen,
Kinder und Neugeborene ―
ohne den Flugtransport
könnten diese nicht überleben.
Sie gehen generell anders um
mit Leben und Tod.
Der Tod ist viel näher als bei uns.
Wenn man hier
etwas Schlimmeres hat ...
Bis man im Spital ist,
vergeht so viel Zeit.
Ja, das ist die Realität hier.
Der Schweizer fliegt die Patientin
ins 200 km entfernte Spital
in der Hauptstadt Dili.
Die Maschine fliegt vorbei
an bis zu 3'000 m hohen Bergen
und überquert dichten Regenwald.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Ich habe gar nicht geschaut, wie alt
sie ist und was mit ihr passiert.
Ich schaue das medizinische Trans-
ferformular jeweils nicht genau an.
Es ist sicher gut,
dass sie jetzt ins Spital kommt.
Ob sie sich vom Herzinfarkt
erholen kann, weiss ich nicht.
Ja ... Das hat sicher einen Einfluss
auf ihre Gesundheit.
Diese Arbeit ist Alltag für Daniel.
Er hat gelernt, mit den Schicksalen,
denen er täglich begegnet, umzugehen.
Seit vier Jahren fliegt Daniel
Hilfseinsätze in Osttimor.
Mittlerweile hat er akzeptiert,
dass das Leben hier
nach anderen Regeln funktioniert.
Man wäre frustriert,
wenn man das Gefühl hätte,
dass diese Insel
schweizerisch funktionieren muss.
Das wäre nichts.
Aber hinter diesem Tor wartet dafür
ein kleines Stück Heimat auf ihn:
Seine Frau Deborah und Sohn Eli.
Hey, du, ciao.
Kommst du zu Dada?
Dada!
- Hallo.
Was hast du heute gemacht, Eli?
- Lauter Blödsinn.
Lauter Blödsinn? Nein.
Ja, ja, ja,
jetzt gibt es gleich ein Geschrei.
* Hupen *
Du könntest doch gleich Auto fahren,
Eli?
Komm, wir gehen essen, mjam, Pizza.
Es gibt Pizza!
Für mich ist das
das Highlight des Tages:
Wenn ich nach Hause komme,
meine Frau sehe und den Kleinen,
der auf mich zukommt.
Das ist sicher
ein Austausch von Liebe.
Beten wir, Eli.
Ja, beten.
- Dann essen wir weiter.
Vater, wir sind dankbar für den Tag,
den wir hatten,
für das, was wir erledigen konnten,
aber auch das, was mühsam war.
Wir danken dir, dass es Abend ist
und dass wir Essen haben. Amen.
Ich bin mega froh,
dass du Pizza geholt hast.
Das ist gut.
Eli hat Katzenfutter gegessen heute,
wieder einmal.
Aber du musst doch nicht
Katzenfutter essen, du.
Ich dachte, er nimmt das dann
irgendwann mal in den Mund.
Das ist etwas vom Wichtigsten
im Leben,
dass man diese Gefühle austauscht
und nicht für sich behält.
Denn ich bin überzeugt, das, was am
Schluss bleibt, ist nicht das Geld,
es sind nicht Dinge,
die ich heimbringe,
diese Beziehung ist das Wichtigste.
(Beide) # I ghöre es Glöggli,
das lütet so nätt.
# De Tag isch vergange,
jetzt gahn i is Bett.
Auf der anderen Seite der Erdkugel,
am Fuss der Anden,
liegt der kleine Ort Uspallata.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Stefan ist am Vorabend angekommen.
Morgen will er
mit seinem Heissluftballon
zur Fahrt über die Anden starten.
Das Wetter ist super.
Dort hat es einige Wolken und da
hinten schneit es, aber sonst ...
Heute fahren er und die übrigen
Ballonfahrer zum Basecamp,
auf 2'500 m Höhe.
Die Vorbereitung für eine Fahrt über
die Anden oder ein grösseres Gebirge
ist natürlich extrem wichtig.
Das Wetter muss stimmen -
wie ist der Wind beim Start?
Habe ich überhaupt die Chance,
aus dem Tal zu starten?
Auch sicherheitsmässig usw.
Das muss man sich alles überlegen.
Damit man entweder starten kann
oder merkt, dass es nicht geht.
* Rasante Gitarrenklänge *
Aber je tiefer der Bus
ins Gebirge fährt,
desto schlechter wird das Wetter.
Stefan hatte zwar
eine Kaltfront erwartet -
aber diese Aussichten
bereiten ihm Sorgen.
Die Gruppe erreicht das Basecamp
in Puente del Inca.
Von hier aus wollen die Ballon-
piloten am nächsten Tag starten.
Aber Stefan hat Zweifel.
Er will sich den Startplatz
heute noch ansehen,
um zu wissen,
was ihn morgen erwartet.
Die Bedingungen waren so:
Es schneite extrem.
Hast du
eine Temperaturanzeige im Auto?
-4 °C.
- Okay, thank you.
Es windete wie verrückt, 50 km/h
Bodenwind, der Schnee verweht.
Es war eigentlich ein Wunder,
dass wir da rumfahren durften.
Wir sind hier
genau auf einer Wettergrenze.
Wir haben genug Wind im Norden,
aber gegen Süden bricht der Wind ab
bis runter auf 10 Knoten.
In 6'000 m Höhe. Das kann ganz
heftige Turbulenzen geben.
Ich hoffe,
wir können überhaupt fliegen morgen.
Aber plötzlich werden Stefan
und seine Begleiter angehalten.
* Rufe auf Spanisch *
Die argentinische Polizei
lässt die Gruppe nicht weiterfahren.
Der Wind hier oben
sei zu unberechenbar
und die Strassen zu gefährlich.
Sie sind hier relativ militärisch.
Es hiess ganz klar: umkehren.
Stefan und sein Team
müssen die wichtige Erkundungsfahrt
ergebnislos abbrechen.
Gerade bei diesem Wetter
wäre für Stefan eine genaue
Vorbereitung wichtig gewesen.
Es schlug mir im ersten Moment
schon auf die Laune.
Ich fragte mich:
"Muss das jetzt sein?"
Und ich merkte,
dass es daran scheitern könnte.
Jetzt sind wir schon
so weit gekommen, bis hierhin,
und wegen einer Kleinigkeit
geht es dann trotzdem nicht auf.
Das produziert in so einem Moment
schon ein wenig Stress.
Es ist Mitternacht.
Reiseführer Joseph verspricht den
Piloten, dass die Körbe und Ballone
pünktlich am nächsten Morgen
eintreffen werden.
Und dass sich das Wetter
bessern sollte.
Trotzdem machen sich
viele Teilnehmer Sorgen.
Als erfahrener Profi versucht Stefan,
die Gruppe zu beruhigen.
... Really strong turbulences,
already with 20 knots.
Da sind Piloten dabei,
die es sich nicht gewohnt sind,
voll in den Bergen zu fliegen -
wie wir in den Alpen.
Da merkte ich, dass es noch Infos
braucht für gewisse Leute,
nicht dass man im Nachhinein
sagen muss:
"Hätte er das gewusst,
wäre es nicht passiert."
Keiner denkt daran,
ins Bett zu gehen.
Noch bis tief in die Nacht
wird weiter diskutiert.
Ob die spektakuläre Ballonfahrt
über die Anden am nächsten Tag
tatsächlich stattfinden kann,
steht in den Sternen.
Durban in Südafrika. Die PC-12
hat wertvolle Fracht an Bord.
Hey Kingston, alles ist gut.
Komm, setz dich auf, Junge.
Du hast ein bisschen heiss, gell?
Das Baby und seine Mutter haben den
90-minütigen Flug gut überstanden.
# You stay young, that's your fault,
there's so much you need to know ...
Sag Tschüss zu unseren zwei Piloten.
Sie haben dich sicher nach Durban
geflogen, um dein Leben zu retten.
Du wirst uns sicher vermissen.
Hello, I'm Doctor Misha, hello.
Kingston wird noch am gleichen Tag
am Herzen operiert.
Er wird den Eingriff
bestens überstehen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ja, wir sind auf dem Weg.
Okay, wunderbar. Bis gleich.
Ciao.
2 Std. später. Misha ist zurück
in Maun und hat endlich Feierabend.
Zu Hause wartet Ehemann Christian
bereits mit dem Nachtessen.
Hunger?
- Ja.
Oh, das sieht gut aus.
Das ist genau, was die Frau braucht.
Zum Essen
kommt Misha trotzdem noch nicht.
Ein Safari Ranger kommt vorbei.
This part of my body is fine.
Es ist nur hier der Arm,
der nicht sehr gut aussieht.
Setz dich da hin.
Ich schau's mir schnell an.
Der Ranger
wurde von einer Spinne gebissen.
Okay, du brauchst eine Infusion,
Antibiotika, Schmerzmittel -
und einen Whiskey!
Schau, diese Pillen habe ich gestern
in der Apotheke gekauft.
Ja, die sind nichts.
Nein, die sind nichts.
Es tut sogar noch mehr weh.
Dass die Spinnenbisse schwerwiegende
Krankheitsbilder hervorrufen,
liegt meist daran, dass ihre
Gefährlichkeit nicht erkannt wird.
Das kann ganz böse ausgehen,
wenn man es nicht mit Antibiotika
aggressiv behandelt.
Es ist unglaublich,
wie sehr sowas Kleines schmerzt.
Es fühlt sich an, als ob es
bis auf den Knochen runter ginge.
Ja das würde es auch.
Vielen Dank und zum Wohl.
- To your good health.
Auf eure Gesundheit auch.
Well, thank you.
Und nächste Woche
bei "Schweizer Helden der Lüfte":
Chaos vor der ersten Ballonfahrt
in Argentinien.
Stefan
findet seine Sauerstofflasche nicht.
Das ist extrem frustrierend -
das kann doch nicht sein.
Aber ich habe wenigstens
den Korb gefunden.
Sascha und Dominic
jagen ihrem ersten Tornado hinterher
und geraten in eine Gewitterzelle.
Da ist eine schlimme Zelle
unterwegs,
ich weiss nicht:
Schaffen wir es oder nicht?
Hallo, George.
Jonas trifft auf den Grossmeister
des Segelfliegens -
und erlebt eine Enttäuschung.
Als ich es hörte, fragte ich mich
schon: Fliege ich so scheisse?
Und auch Misha und Daniel heben
wieder ab, um Leben zu retten.
* Hoffnungsvolle Klänge *